soit il y a aussi les bonnes nouvelles
des événements qui confirme que l'on
peut croire au progrès dans le domaine
médical ce sont le diagnostic et la
technologie prénatal qui bénéficient ces
derniers temps des avancées les plus
spectaculaires ainsi on vient
d'apprendre qu'à lyon une greffe de
cellules a été réussi sur un foetus de
sept mois atteints d'un déficit
immunitaire mortels une greffe effectuée
donc dans le ventre de la mère c'est une
première mondiale réalisée il ya
quelques mois par le professeur touraine
à l'hôpital edouard herriot de lyon est
tenue secrète jusqu'ici à la demande de
la famille le bébé n'est normalement
depuis est encore dans une bulle pour
quelques mois
cette technique représente donc un
nouvel espoir pour les enfants bull
jusqu'ici on avait réussi des greffes
mais après la naissance c'est grâce à
cette technique que nous allons
rencontrer avec alain labouze et pierre
laurent constants un garçon de 12 ans en
pleine forme il s'appelle certains
furent
condamnés à mourir parce qu'incapable de
se défendre contre les infections sergio
qui a aujourd'hui 12 ans l'a échappé
belle les 18 premiers mois de sa vie il
les a passées dans une bulle il n'y
avait pas de donneur de moelle
compatibles et puis un jour à lyon on a
tenté l'impossible la greffe de tissus
provenant de foetus mort et ça a marché
par contre que j'ai pas initié par terre
j'ai été solide pas comme un but parce
que ces thèmes aussi sympathique
j'en fais des rumeurs moment je peux
tomber dans la le temps infiniment je
peux enfin d'après ce que m'a dit avant
qu'il allait faire
j'avais pas tellement d'efforts non en
fait qu'elle est la grève sous gestion
je sais qu'il a des goûts et des saveurs
salées pas
c'est ici dans ce laboratoire que l'on
prépare les cellules de foie et de
thymus extraites des foetus mort à ce
jour 51 enfants ont pu être greffés avec
ses cellules 66% sont définitivement
guéri
il y a à peu près une centaine d'enfants
à traiter chaque année soit près
naissance soit avant la naissance par
une greffe de cellules foetales nous
manquons de ces cellules ce qui est
important c'est que nous soyons prévenus
chaque fois qu'un foetus décède dans une
ville de france pour que nous puissions
faire le prélèvement est organisée la
transplantation on n'a pas le droit
d'utiliser des foetus mort disent
certains et pourtant c'est la seule
façon aujourd'hui de sauver des enfants
comme sérgio